a structured start to what quickly
became a fiery emotional ad-lib a
frustrated Donald Trump changing gear
defending far-right protesters in
Charlottesville you had many people in
that group other than neo-nazis and
white nationalists okay and the press
has treated them absolutely unfairly now
in the other group also you had some
fine people but you also had
troublemakers and you see them come with
a with the black outfits and with the
helmets and with the baseball bats you
got a you had a lot of bad you had a lot
of bad people in the other group a day
before at the White House reading from a
script' he condemned white nationalists
singling out the groups other members of
his party already had but back home in
New York he took aim at what he sees as
the other side what about the alt left
they came charging at the as you say the
alt right do they have any semblance of
guilt he denounced the driver accused of
killing had a hair but avoided
definitions driver of the car is a
disgrace to himself his family in this
country and that is you can call it
terrorism you can call it murder you can
call it whatever you want but President
Trump insisted many were there to simply
oppose a Confederate statue being taken
down before asking what next
this week it's robert e lee i noticed
that stonewall jackson's coming down i
wonder is it George Washington next week
and is it Thomas Jefferson the week
after you know you all you really do
have to ask yourself where does it stop
this was a press conference for the
history books
if the president's remarks on Monday
were what his advisors wanted him to say
this was an army ported look at what he
really feels the concern is that it
might undo his efforts to try and calm
the waters more senior business leaders
have left his manufacturing council and
senior Republicans were left clamoring
to clarify their positions the Speaker
of the House Paul Ryan tweeted we must
be clear white supremacy is repulsive
this bigotry is counter to all this
country stands for there can be no moral
ambiguity outside Trump Tower more
evidence of a deepening divide and the
instant impact of an unorthodox leader
who gave a window into what he really
believes it was a candid impromptu
moment that could define his presidency
woody reelect skinny's New York